-Today is Friday, and that's
usually when I catch up
with some personal stuff.
I check my in-box,
I return some e-mails,
and, of course,
send out thank-you notes.
And I was running a bit
behind today,
so I thought if
you guys wouldn't mind,
could I write out my weekly
thank-you notes right now?
[ Cheers and applause ]
During the show.
This will be perfect.
Maybe if I can get some
thank-you-note-writing music
from happy James.
Happy James?
[ Soft music playing ]
He's so happy.
-Wow. That is happy James.
Aww!
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you,
Ticketmaster crashing
because so many people wanted
Taylor Swift tickets.
Or as Ticketmaster put it,
"It's me.
Hi.
I'm the problem. It's me."
[ Humming "Anti-Hero" ]
♪♪
That's a good jam.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you,
airplane neck pillows,
for making it look like I fell
asleep in a velvet toilet.
"Don't flush! Don't flush!"
-"Don't flush!
It's a velvet toilet."
"He's so rich.
He had a velvet toilet."
[ Soft music playing, stops ]
Is your --
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, Earth's population,
for hitting 8 billion.
If we all chip in 6 bucks, we
can buy Twitter back from Elon.
Come on. Let's do it.
Let's do it! Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm in.
-Wow.
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you,
moving walkways at airports
for letting me get to my gate
a whole three seconds faster.
I do go on them anyway, though.
-I do, too.
Even if they're broken.
-They're fun.
-Yeah.
-It's the future right there.
-Yeah. I feel like the Jetsons.
-Yes!
-Yeah.
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you, "Yellowstone,"
for proving that
parents can figure out
streaming apps.
♪♪
-Come on!
-Good joke.
-Yeah. Topical. Yeah.
-Peacock.
-Yeah. Peacock, man.
-Peacock all the way, man.
-The P.
-Peacock -- your nickname,
you call it "The P"?
-Yeah, well, it's better than
the other one.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
It's a family show.
[ Soft music playing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Rimshot ]
-You got me on that one.
You gotta make a T-shirt.
We gotta make
a T-shirt, right?
-If they knew what --
That's what's up.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know, I know.
You just -- Yeah, the people
at Peacock are like,
"He's onto something."
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, man.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Friendsgiving,
for being when friends
gather together with
a turkey, three sides,
and 20 bottles of cheap wine.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-"I brought the wine!"
[ Soft music playing ]
-Thank you,
French's Fried Onions,
for figuring out
the secret to getting people
to eat green beans is putting
a different, better food on top.
"That was Yummy, I need more.
What's the secret?"
"Uh, I put Doritos all over it."
-"Oh, my God! Delicious."
-Mwah!
Oh, yeah, this is good.
[ Soft music playing ]
Thank you, Thanksgiving,
or as the fold-out tables
in your garage put it,
"Our time to shine, bish."
There you have it.
Those are our "Thank You Notes."